on va plutôt faire la fête des écrans et
parfois c'est un peu compliqué sarah
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire avec un
thème d'actualité qu'on connaît tous si
on a des enfants des petits enfants
toujours un peu compliqué quand on met
des jeux vidéo mobile vous avez des
enfants patrick hervé dix enfants c'est
rock'n'roll parfois avec les écrans et
jeux vidéo tout le temps très bien c'est
parce que vous n'aviez pas encore
rencontré sarah voilà effectivement je
suis je suis là aujourd'hui pour vous
parler c'est déjà parce que cette année
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
classé en fait les troubles du jeu vidéo
dans la catégorie des troubles liés à
l'addiction
donc c'est la première fois un petit peu
court rapproché ces deux terminaux en
fait il ya des choses très simples qui
peuvent être mises en place par les
parents des choses qui parfois ne sont
pas toujours ceux des reflex qu'on peut
adopter c'est pas toujours des choses
qu'on sait par exemple la première
première chose dont je voulais vous
parler c'est l'écran la ouais c'est ça
c'est une classification en fait une
classification européenne qui a été mise
en place et qui s'appelle pegi voilà ça
aurait envoyé là donc en fait sur chaque
boîte de jeu que vous achetez dans le
commerce parce que très souvent en tout
cas on espère que la plupart du temps ce
sont les parents qui achètent des jeux
aux enfants
voilà il existe des petits des petits
pictos comme ça donc en fait chaque
picto signifie quelque chose
ces voix là c'est une classification qui
a élaboré selon plusieurs critères que
je vais pas vous détailler ici parce
qu'on n'aura pas le temps mais voilà
pegi 12 voix la violence etc
en l'occurrence ça signifie que c'est
déconseillé aux enfants de moins de 12
ans ça va jusqu'à 18 et il existe aussi
des descripteurs ce qu'ils appellent les
descripteurs de contenus péguy ou là on
peut voir que par exemple dans ce jeu il
y aura de la violence la bad langage ça
veut dire qu'il y aura très probablement
des injures ou des insultes
et voilà il ya tout d il ya tout un tas
de petits pictos comme ça c'est très
important d'y faire attention parce que
ça peut permettre déjà de dire à
l'enfant
non ce jeu là il fait pas partie de la
catégorie d'âge si je vous dis par
exemple fortnight parce que tous les
gamins sur sur fortnight alors forte
naïve un peu on va on va regarder je
vais voir chercher fortnight parce que
sur ce site internet qui est super bien
fait ça je voudrais tu as fait vous
pouvez taper le jeu que vous voulez en
fait dans la barre de recherche 12
et là il vous a dit donc forte nice et
12 sachant qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'enfants qui ont moins de 12
qu'ils jouent voilà c'est vraiment aux
parents de faire attention et de
responsabiliser l'enfant et vis-à-vis de
ce voyage était aussi j'étais à gesté
paraître un peu bizarre pour ceux qui
nous regardent ça vous parle peut-être
pas gta mais pour ceux qui ont des
enfants gt1 ça fait partie des pop stars
aussi des jeux gta
trouvez-moi le le débat gta vous allez
être les deux gt gt je pense que ça va
calmer tout le monde ce matin à 10h27
voilà j'ai trouv pas parce que je vais
vous le dire parce que je veux c'est mon
ami cela à mon avis ça va être ça vous
n'avez pas mis les majuscules sais pas
c'est un pegi 18 en fait ah oui parce
que c'est un jeu très violent est là il
ya de la violence et du sexe c'est bon
très bien un jeu auquel il faut faire
attention
j'imagine que pour les parents il ya des
règles enfin au niveau mieux y penser
quand même voilà c'est ça comme pour la
télé comme pour le téléphone on peut
mettre en place ce qu'on peut appeler
les règles du jeu donc ces règles du jeu
ça dépend de l'âge de l'enfant de son
caractère aussi voilà faut faire
attention à ça de son rythme scolaire et
du rythme pour lequel il a d'autres
activités enfin si c'est un enfant qui
fait beaucoup de sport ou si c'est un
enfant qui sont souvent reclus souvent
isolés voilà c'est des choses auxquelles
il faut faire attention et aussi des
catégories d'âge
on sait qu'avant trois ans où le répète
assez souvent et notamment dans cette
émission c'est déconseillé
les écrans sont déconseillés pour pour
les enfants la logique d'ailleurs
oui d'abord pédagogique qui s'appelle
pédagojeux alors c'est pas pour les
enfants c'est surtout pour les parents
parce que souvent voilà le premier
réflexe est d'éduquer les parents avant
d'éduquer les enfants c'est très
important c'est un site qui est très
bien fait et là en fait il explique donc
vous pouvez retrouver des fiches des
fiches pratiques ça c'est assez
intéressant c'est ça voilà donc jeux
vidéo ea jeux vidéo et argent et en
cliquant sur les fichiers des petits
conseils à chaque fois qu'ils sont
donnés
ça c'est des choses qui sont très
intéressante
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que
entre 3 et 6 ans l'enfant là il est dans
la découverte donc c'est pas qu'il n'est
pas question pour lui qui sont autonomes
dans sa pratique du jeu vidéo on peut
donner aussi comme conseils vous pouvez
très bien joué avec votre enfant
ça va vous permet de rentrer dans son
univers pouvoir en discuter plus
facilement au delà de 6 ans l'enfant
commence à être plus autonomes et là il
faut faire attention ici parce que
l'enfant peut commencer à jouer en
réseau et quand ils jouent en réseau ce
qui est important c'est de lui expliquer
comment fonctionne le réseau je parle de
sa taille tout a lancé ce jour aux jeux
en réseau donc là il est en rapport aux
failles dans liens avec des gens
il peut être amené à voile à elle-même a
discuté avec eux faut lui expliquer
comment ça fonctionne au delà de 13 ans
voilà l'enfant commence à être autonome
et toujours garder un oeil sur sur sa
fréquence de jeu et c'est la durée de
jeu bon évidemment ça dépend du
caractère de l'enfant du temps scolaire
et puis rappelons quand même que il ya
la vraie vie à côté que c'est bon de
sessa de la montre et voilà la vraie vie
et la vie internet vous en parler au
sein d'une association qui s'appelle tu
interne était compagnie je l'avais
d'internet parce qu'à côté il ya un bd
fil alors je dis tintin non c'est un tel
internet
voilà c'est à besançon pour être très
précis mais cerion partout grâce à la
magie du net voilà